dude I was thinking about this about
animals and and humans all right
I think humans
I got this theory that like animals
because animals are on four legs right
they're on four legs so their Earth
they're like really connected with
nature you know humans are kind of the
only species that isn't super connected
with nature
you know we are but we're also kind of
not
and one of the things that I was
thinking about was
because animals they're on the Earth
right their hands touch the Earth and
their legs
right and so the Earth kind of like it
makes a circuit through their body
so you know they're they're
they you know they have a completed
circuit with the Earth and so it's like
everything that the Earth is all the
nature that's inside of the earth and
the elements of nature that goes right
through the animal through its whatever
legs or feet or arms and comes out you
know it's just part of the circle part
of the cycle
and then humans we're standing up
so we're kind of like this loose cable
where it's like you got the energy like
the connection from the earth comes in
but then it starts rattling because it's
not getting out
you know and I think that's one of like
I don't know if that's like if that made
us develop like some of the way that we
think because we have all this weird and
like this energy that doesn't have like
an outlet some other animals that are on
two legs you have
let me see
kangaroo look at that [ __ ] dog now that
[ __ ] ain't doing well bruh
let's be honest bruh when you see a
kangaroo that [ __ ] ain't doing well
dude they making babies in their pocket
they're fighting each look they got yeah
their fists fighting they're making
babies in their uh in their
ah
you know they're they're uterus is like
in a dam
you know they got like a fanny pack
front uterus I don't know what they're
doing there yeah they fight yeah they
got children hiding out their wiener
hole or whatever I mean it doesn't none
of it makes yeah look at them they're
fighting they're beating people
they had a couple of them ran through a
fence somewhere the other day but they I
mean and nothing about the animal looks
like it's doing well either they look
like somebody was trying to do something
and then like the lab got busted
you know they look like some kind of
Frankenstein dude was trying to put some
[ __ ] together
and then the cops rolled up and he was
like ah [ __ ] it I'm out of here and then
that thing
just beat through the damn drywall bro
them [ __ ] are gang bangers son
dude if you were I mean if I I'm sure in
the animal kingdom these are like the
MS-13 of animals these are the Bloods
and the crypts and the whatever you know
I mean these things will pop
look at this I mean here's one right
here my God
I mean this one obviously
I mean this this one probably owns a
yacht bro I mean these things are [ __ ]
up
they're in a crypto that's a [ __ ] that's
a kangaroo
I mean this thing is modeling you got to
see some of these videos and get the
picture down there with the Mexican kids
he's trying to fit in with the family to
get out of the country look at this [ __ ]
dude that thing is crazy bro and look at
that wiener and the Mexicans right there
I mean what's going on but yeah anything
that obviously so that's what we are
we're almost like this kangaroo but
we're all it's just mostly in our head
we don't know what's going on because
we're stuck on two legs we're not
completing this this the uh circuit
so I think that's something that could
have happened to humans is at some point
you know whenever we got on two legs it
just
you know that energy gets stuck in our
brain at the end of us so of course it
would make our brain really advanced
and then
since we don't have our life sources
we're not connected back to the Earth
then we would start to create a higher
power we'd have to start to create some
reason
because I think if you're connected to
the Earth you're a four-legged animal
then the reason just flows through you
and you know it
um
so I don't know I was thinking about
that what if the energy that doesn't
because usually if like you're part of
nature then you know the energy just
comes up and goes out you right you're
you're that connected loop with your
because you're four-legged
but if you're two-legged then the energy
is just going to come in
and not be able to get out
so then I wonder if maybe that's one of
the reasons why we started thinking
about having like gods and stuff like
that because before if the energy went
right back into the Earth and if we just
knew we were part of the same source
you know we knew it was all connected
but if not if it just the energy just
kind of rattles in this cul-de-sac
then it I could see it start to manifest
ideas of like
like gods or higher powers or something
like that because it's not connected to
the source like it's supposed to be
so I don't know if that makes any sense
but I feel like maybe we're supposed to
be on four
limbs
you know that's why I think when you do
yoga and stuff that stuff for you it
makes you feel so keyed in you know
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one